[Music]
has taken a bit of damage early on but
there should be no
chance just equalize the score or he's
hiding right at the edge of the smoke
config doesn't know it snacks trying to
sneak up behind him
convic not really aware what's going on
yet this could be a lost ak very quick
and the timing here he's favoring snacks
in
is he really going to go for the knife
oh my god
he changed with a knife in the quarter
finals
guys while you were learning ak sprays
and mid smokes these players studied the
blade
that's right this week on best dub we're
talking about the best knife kills
in cs go now tell me what's better than
making 1500 extra bucks
and putting the fear of god in the enemy
team at the same time
am i right
detective jefferson may i help you
i'll call you back and we're not just
dealing with these sneaky beaky knife
kills either oh no we're going to show
you the best
yolo don't give up knife kills and the
best
worst knife kills which i guess you call
fails
these are the start of that really so
okay
so let's start things off with some
stealthy knife plays that'll make you
want to smile
it's all right and yeah right on the
edge looking for it he's used this smoke
before
trying to find oh let's do it i love it
so he's like i know exactly what you're
up to no worries
get out of the server yeah this is
stewie's turn
dignitas go for the retake they did such
a good job at doing this on cash
can they do it again nico gets occasion
b k dean is coming around the back side
of them gets a glimpse of one it's going
to be an easy
thing but he gets him at the end gets
him with the knife
kady and goes big and that is what they
needed
just an actual terminator
triple here yes
papa i mean it's a psychological warfare
isn't it
splashed for a moment accidentally it's
just hunting
for hobbit now he's in the showers
just like in prison moses you've got to
be careful
you never know what can happen is so
close down
at this point should realize that he
needs to just rush into the site and try
and die
but he's what if he faces him after the
round's over too insult to injury
[Music]
yeah there it is [ __ ]
that's a massive mistake to not just die
there we go we got there in the end and
pasha he'll creep through the smoke but
what can you get done here with his p250
as he calls behind the lines finds box
and he's creeping he's looking to see if
he can find more players very smart
stuff here from pasha when is he going
to pull the trigger or will he pull out
the knife the precision insisted
the precision incision is there the
lannisters send their regards
can they deal with fx job here actually
gary does pick up the opening kill there
on gmx so that's really good
fx shows waiting timing is everything
he's going to be jumping down does make
some noise but not enough oh
then master said he only gets one more
kill but that might be enough
absolutely brilliant that nip are
destroyed
like burned caged in alive that's the
awp player down so if flushing can pick
up this kill
they're trying to pinch out of magisk it
does open up the site snyder's gonna do
it instead by wrapping around they'll go
for the default
plant just in time five seconds when he
gets it
on to the plant and onto the line one hp
versus two
there's three hp between two players
left in a one versus one post plant
overtime of an elimination matching
config might get the upper hand
take your time take your time to injury
in overtime
that is bold why would you do that i
didn't even think about it
for us to sit back at pop dog walk back
in he's got a shot at line
takes down nico that brings it level but
watch to his left side because i don't
think he's aware of the guardian stuck
up in this pistol at this range
with no attention from for his lethal
he's looked a main but he's not look
towards the train guardians whipped it
that could be enough to turn it because
now fur has the information they're able
to work this together
and just the pistols to play with they
needed the kill guardians got to make up
for it he's tapping him but he can't
find it fallen's on the defuse
fallen is on the defuse the lineup he's
still darren
he doesn't have the
[Applause]
how does he deny that in that situation
that should have been done
also the the tech nine there easy couple
of kills for him or the one killer
flusher
now one versus five he's even being
bringing around the rosie here pascha's
waiting oh don't do it
pasha that's so crawly nice flusher and
that will be
it if they weren't already winning if
they weren't already completely
deconstructing here then that's it
all right oh my god i'm just waiting for
it
how can this this can't be real life
that is so next level the spot amount as
he goes around the corner everyone faces
shots point taps and as he repeats back
out wp has to back off from keith
if he finds the shot on goffy don't pull
him out he's got it as well
he's only got 12 hp but he's lost track
where he is the shot he's on it
keep why is he not picking he goes for
the knight oh my goodness
you talking about config bm and it'll
just be terrific now
he doesn't have a flank he has meant to
successfully sneak around so maybe he
can steal away one kill but that's
probably
the largest thing he's gonna be able to
find here go for the knife
yes cut it out oh oh that's unfortunate
they're gonna find him too when he fix
that again nope
now we do it no what is happening right
now
he wants to get the back he doesn't want
to take any chances on missing
it's like one of those old school games
where like the npc goes and like to see
the same movement come on i've had
enough
yeah there you go guys we've all played
pub games where the only logical
conclusion
comes down to whip out the knife i mean
run out of bullets
without the knife enemy with his back
turned whip out the knife
round gone to [ __ ] entire team on tilt
you know what to do
without the knife i can beat you i don't
need no
gun i gotta kill
you now is this one possible notoriously
one of the most difficult to retake
and it looks like niko will be going
down his spawn they're going for the
knife attempt here be careful tapson
and he'll get him oh they're liking that
one they'll at least
get them a bit of morale into the next
style i almost feel like nico just gave
up from the second shot he's like all
right you got me he locked me in here
just have it
all of these braids are working on
turret with a massive spray down getting
a double stewie to follow it up
and crystal on the other side might as
well pack it up here
nothing left to achieve stewie trying to
hunt him down
peaks it up with a jump flashes us in
knife is sounding he's going to get
stabbed crystal
oh my god what a brutal round yes that
is stewie with a psychological warfare
or he had to stay alive but he couldn't
really hide after that first one forest
wild flash gonna take down civics what a
big kill and he's got to see set out
goes for more takes dupree he's ready
with the orb he scopes through a knife
him oh my god takes down device he's
gonna get gutted and
energy begin to retake automatic take
some more bullets down to 29.
he's eating them like candies at this
point skadoodle has to go off he's the
last one towards sight
he has a glock of course and he's able
to hit and jay somehow
out of bullets out of the knife
skadoodle what's he doing on double
knife can he get the third
he gets the right click and rush finds
zap skadoodle the double
knife two versus two and 33 seconds to
work with but still navi
looms large inside of this a sight with
cease just hoping to get the angle
and simple thoughts i'm not bothered
can't land the shot but they know where
he is
each door or each other are and that
also means that zeus can start to probe
in exactly where simple as jdm needs to
get there fast the jump down like shot
on the nose scope but a knife
he has to do something because he can't
get the gun drawn in time
or still rattling on through flame he's
going to push on through but kenny's
found him
and now it's all on guardian will he try
and hold the off he gets the shot onto
apex
is he going to try and go huge here
kenny is on site straight in his face
doesn't hit
[Applause]
15 seconds to be planted and kenny i
don't i wouldn't be challenging jw right
now he's on it he's feeling hot about
this and oh he's coming
no way absolute filth from jw's
and it's nitro that's super close in
this pop flash one gets by is he gonna
find him in time he does
turns back nearly gets the second one on
the a slope as well there it is just
kind of remains does manage to find one
there's gonna be a four on one situation
once again
he doesn't really have anything to work
with just gonna be trying to get one
more crack out of it
smoked out bomb down everyone chasing
down gets a dremel the knife comes in
simple of course stabs him straight in
the chest
and takes him down just insults her
injury this guy is having an absolute
dream of a match
happy goes down a lot of the setup for
envy's going to be but look at this he
actually sees two people flush her
blind shot takes down apex and now
they're in the b bomb side flushing
getting a chance to reload back up
it's already here making shima with a
stunning shot a shot down olofmeister
it's now a 4v4
jw still alive kenny gets a kill on
crimson's flusher in the back lines
he's out of
fox he's the wild card in all of this
meanwhile trying to get on the flank
he's gonna spot it fall and not ready
for this at all turns around manages to
somehow win the duel
four range as well with the clock and
now fox prime position said he would be
there has to try and follow this up and
watch to his left it's a crossfire
it's a blunder both go to the knife
gold's gonna win it off and then there
is a knife because device comes back
around
oh my god device with two in one round
[Music]
[Music]
you never spread straight it's just the
standard
it's gonna be it's bro i can't do that
to ski doodle man
guys getting a kill with your knife is
one of the best feelings you can have
in a competitive cs go match i gotta
tell you
this is pretty terrific yeah
i mean you make extra money you put the
entire enemy team on tilt
and you kind of feel like a badass but
sometimes guys
sometimes pulling out the knife is not
the right play
i did not see that coming it's looking
grim for sk
yeah it seizes on the flank from this b
bomb site so cold i mean he's at least
hidden for now but if he comes through
this murder hole then cold has
no chance of surviving this battle he's
not even appearing it's going to be a
knife
there would have been there would have
been sort of collective spanking later
on
oh i mean even device sniping his
teammate i think he's probably the one
they'd focus on
what that can't be real
i just can't be real he's gonna play a
bit of ring around the rosie the first
target that was caught while he's
mid-air so it's hard to aim it as
nowhere
but to look and for kiyoshima it'll be
able to move in taking down
fallen and giving faze a little bit of
hope here to start off the second half
that was the four on two in favor to
faze at the start of that really so
okay what
[Music]
rain why'd you have to be like this i
know he had a bad half but snacks covers
off the lower tunnels and they've got
all the map control patches in behind
them they're locked
down in this hallway they've got to kill
snacks just to get anywhere further on
the map he pops out
he's got no support of the duel no
betraying potential so he's gotta get
the bonus only he's got one
but they're both out of ammo it's gonna
be a night for snacks to start it off
top of his position as flamey wins his
tool he can back down to try and look
through control
but it's not gonna work out his favor
bomb goes down that will
all they have to do is hold that on the
ground simple what okay fair enough
what's going on scouts honor i salute
you forest majors sitting here in the
back of the site i mean they're gonna go
put this bomb down
meanwhile pit has fallen 2v4 we've seen
an ip clutch rounds from these kind of
situations before but they've been
smoked off
this makes it that much harder for us
charges through he is going to find
himself in the receiving end of a
battering here comes get right he gets
knife but peeks around
and destroys twist perfect position to
strike on
who's not going to check and he's got
the bomb in first they've dropped the
bomb out way in the open they may get
away with it because the silhouette if
they're going to leave
with kills but for a moment that that
was horrendous
now crypt is going to come in through
the smoke fitness himself too
the way this guy's playing right now
he's unstoppable and nifty
has to pull off a 1v3 of his own my god
crims that was
filth he just pushes through the smoke
he's got a shooting gallery they've got
no idea what to do
the planter just looks absolutely lost
in jw doesn't want another knife
i think he does vince he's coming in it
could go wrong and it is
he's there flusha in the one versus one
the bloodlust
the greed and now this round could be up
for debate the molotov will come through
if flasher doesn't win this jw's gonna
feel very embarrassed indeed
but it's all absolutely fine okay i
would be absolutely fuming from jw
would you i'm feeling with him i'm not
even on this team
like the difference is your crims
especially you've just done that do you
see the look on crimson's face he's like
you
i'm not going to say this well guys
that's it for best of this week
i hope you got your fill of butterfly
flipping karambit spinning action
now go ahead and stab that subscribe
button and i'll see you next week
so let's start things off with some
stealthy knife plays that'll make you
want to smile
ear to ear
[Music]
okay i've started all your moves
yes study this
oh are you sure okay